what has happened in their citizens of
the reject Nation we have some DC
Resurgence news let's keep going through
what's going on with DC because you know
they're always zigzagging around and
regurgitating old stories and then
getting updates and then getting updates
shut down we got stuff to talk about
regarding Ben Affleck and James Gunn
John how are you I'm good I'm excited to
play DC news Mad Libs today how are you
I'm excited too it's a good game we
should call that new segment until uh
you know Commando creatures or whatever
that's it well first things first you
know what to do please go ahead leave a
like I point today I'm a pointer leave a
like that mean a lot also want to give
another mention myself this guy and koi
genre we are going to be having a panel
Sunday March 26th 11 o'clock A.M at
WonderCon it's real rejects exclusive
we'd love to have you join I'm going to
talk about the current state of the MCU
and DCU fandom side of it you know how
fun that could be anywho let's get into
this Ben Affleck story Ben Affleck was
doing an interview with the Hollywood
repor order to talk about his new movie
air and then The Hollywood Reporter was
like we don't give a about that
tell us more about Batman thoughts and
DC that's all we care about that's what
we'll get the clicks
we don't even know what this air movie
is about you probably don't even know
Ben Affleck so there was a few things
that were brought up like I said
regurgitated you know one one cool thing
was that he talked about Zack Snyder's
Justice League being his highest rated
movie on IMDb he seems to look back
fondly on specifically that version of
Justice League he he again reiterates
how awful the Justice League path ended
up turning into but then there was a
question that was asked that has led
many people many many many people I this
is the main thing I'm seeing online to
be like James Gunn you are a
pathological liar kick him off of
Twitter I have some thoughts about that
that I want to go over what Ben Affleck
first said and then I want to go over if
I think James Gunn was indeed lying or
not regardless it's not a good look
but I have some thoughts so here's what
was going on uh he was asked how did you
approach Michael Jordan about that I'm
just kidding I don't care about air
let's talk about DC so if DC came to you
now and said do you want to direct
something John do your best Ben Affleck
impression I would not direct something
for the not enough Boston in there I
would not direct something for James
Gunn's flipping DC you absolutely not I
have nothing against James Gunn nice guy
Sherry's gonna do a great job I just
don't wanna I I wouldn't want to go in
and Direct in the New York now in a way
that they're doing that I'm not
interested in that now you see the
reason why people were going wait a
minute wait a minute but James Gunn he
said not long ago when he was asked
could Ben Affleck direct something and
James Gunn did say met with Ben
yesterday precisely because he wants to
direct and we want him to direct we just
have to find the right project for him
to direct that created a lot of
excitement because that seems to be one
of the ways James Gunn has been common
the Flames around people when there's so
much discourse over Direction and then
having to restart all over again yeah
we're meeting with Henry Cavill he's
gonna play Wolverine in the DC Universe
everybody he's everybody now we're
saying all kinds of don't worry
we're figuring it out we got it covered
to me like when I heard Ben Affleck
possible I thought that was cool a lot
of people thought he might direct Batman
the Brave and the Bold but then Ben
Affleck's coming in here and he is
firmly stating I would not direct
something for the James Gunn DC
absolutely not he's speaking in
absolutes this guy I just wouldn't want
to go in and Direct in the way they're
doing that I'm not interested in that I
understand why people would say he's a
liar why I think this is not a good look
I personally don't think James Gunn was
lying because there's a gap in time here
a few months I think what probably
happened was he probably did talk to Ben
Affleck I don't think James Gunn would
just put that out there and be like sure
we talked we had a great conference I
don't think he would just say that and
not expect Ben Affleck to be like what
are you doing yeah dude you're just
lying out blatantly to everybody yeah I
mean you're on Twitter all the time like
if anything is a discrepancy or if
anything's wrong you are inviting people
to come in and correct you very publicly
and turn finish your credibility I think
what happened was I had a conversation
maybe Ben Affleck did express interest
in it but in the time of understanding
like oh everything's going to be like
really interconnected they are
fine-tuning and getting more clear on
their definition of how they want the
direction of the DC Universe to go then
eventually Ben Affleck was like you know
what yeah I don't want to be a part of
that the thing though is with with his
answer here he does not acknowledge that
he had a conversation with James Gunn so
it leads a lot of people to be going
James Gunn probably made all that
up yeah well because that thing about he
wants to direct I think is the big sort
of uh point of dissonance here because
it seems like very much not hey this is
the hazard of James Gunn tweeting so
much is that you know a lot of things
can change and a lot of things are just
to Broach a preliminary idea and we
don't know how many times they spoke and
met you know they could have met two or
three more times and then he got to this
conclusion the reason why I was saying
like regardless it's a bad look for
James Gunn is because right now with
again the discourse that's happening
with DC it's leadership everything looks
at leadership and how's that going
because that's going to be a reflection
of how everything moves forward you know
when Marvel's great Kevin feige gets the
praise when Marvel's sucking Kevin feig
gets the blame you know DC has already
had enough ups and downs there's already
been questionable decisions and paths
with James Gunn so having this come out
like what you've said about how like him
being on Twitter too much like this
happens that could backfire I feel like
Ben Affleck's doing everything he can to
move past the DC Universe it would just
again resurrect the whole thing of him
like getting a Batman movie or playing
Batman again you know him talking you
know fondly of what at least everything
he indicates here sounds like he speaks
fondly of of Zack Snyder which I I think
he does I mean he returned for Zack
Snyder's Justice League did to shoot in
his backyard I think he's he thinks
highly of Zach and then the experience
specifically with him however like again
he's promoting a completely different
movie yeah all anyone including
ourselves I give a about it it's
like yeah I want to hear about the DC
thing you're talking about yeah I'm sure
air will be a good movie but let's talk
about your DC stuff sure sure and the
pivot two into James Gunn's Universe I
think that is a good point like it's a
big interconnected thing the Snyder
verse was purportedly supposed to be
much more director driven and so I think
that would more uh directly appeal to
somebody like Ben Affleck and two I mean
he has The Flash coming out which seems
like it could be a chance for him to put
a final stamp on the character and we
don't know what that's going to look
like you know so they said those five
minutes that he was in it were the best
five minutes finally learned how to do
it finally I realized limited amount of
screen time is the way I want to do this
four hours of uh Snyder cut I couldn't
quite crack it but I finally got it here
enjoy everybody just crazy to hear
because I think he's great yeah
give yourself a little credit come on
Ben Ben watches this channel yeah with
it trying everything he can right now to
move faster married Jennifer Lopez give
me a break let me be on top again let me
just enjoy my life so put this Albatross
back around taking photos of me smoking
cigarettes and eating Donuts
against Simon and Garfunkel music and
this is I'm sick of this hashtag let Ben
live all righty guys well what do you
think about this do you feel like James
guns was lying about any of it uh not
about all of it although I would love it
if it did come out that he was like yeah
I never had that conversation with Jenny
oh that's bad yeah and then the rock
comes in he never talked to me either
James Gunn is a candy ass all right guys
leave your thoughts below thanks for
being here and uh let's end this with
Tyler Hague Tyler I feel like you could
be the next Batman you know man you'd be
a perfect more realistic Batman in my
opinion anytime we've talked with you
you're lounging with a bunch of monitors
just watching the world and if you
really were a billionaire with that
level of technology for that amount of
surveillance
yeah I just sit around too and watch it
yeah I wouldn't want everybody's life I
don't want to go out in the streets and
handle crap I'm a billionaire yeah but
do I need to do any of that for is
voyeur on people and then gossip about
them so you would be the perfect Bruce
Wayne we always do with these comic book
movies it's like how much more real can
we go well the more realistic Bruce
Wayne Tyler Hague I think it wouldn't
even risk it it would be you just
relaxed lounging enjoying watching other
people's lives and just being like
I need to go out
I'll call the cops
this is the law enforcement's
responsibility I donate hundreds of
thousands of dollars to the police yes
absolutely well I'm busy paying my taxes
as well
definitely anyway Tyler love you buddy
see you soon